another battle of the hearts and Minds
traditionally played out through
diplomacy and propaganda is being played
out online my next guest has almost half
a billion views for his provocative
commentary online making him hugely
influential Hassan P streams live under
the name Hassan Abby his analysis of the
Israel Hamas War has taken a highly
critical stance towards Israel and
Western media and he's been calling me
out for my coverage because he only
cares about Israeli citizens he does not
care about Palestinians as human beings
that's why it's apples oranges he like
one side is a human the other side is a
barbaric monster child I never said that
obviously he says that he like nothing
more than to come on to unsensored and
call me a baboon in a suit to my face
well here I am a baboon uh and he can
join me now I'm joined by Hassan Hassan
thank you very much to D for coming
on thank you for having me Piers uh it's
very early here in Los Angeles
California but I'm going to try to do my
very best to to not do my British accent
while I'm here well I appreciate that
and listen I appreciate you coming on
explain to me why you consider me a
stenographer for the Israeli government
given that in the last week I think more
than any other host in the world I have
given lengthy platforms to Pro
Palestinian voices to articulate that
side of the
argument no I I I do have to commend you
uh you certainly have uh had more Pro
pal invoices than uh the rest of the
British media and certainly the rest of
Western media in general now as far as
uh saying that you're a stenographer I
said that journalists are not supposed
to be stenographers And yet when it
comes down to it in most circumstances
in whatever conflict uh we may be in
they are stenographers for whichever uh
whichever party is aligning with the
American state department and the
interests of the West in general and
Israel happens to be the one uh in this
in this ongoing conflict it's
interesting that you call me a
propagandist because I want to play you
this was your reaction to when the
hospital got I'm a propagandist the no
no I'm not calling you no no I'm just
saying I'm going toay you say I'm saying
I am okay well then I want to I'm saying
I am you play it okay I'm going to play
the clip this is your reaction to the
bombing of the hospital uh the other
night while I was in the process of of
getting ready for the stream uh Israel
enacted uh one of the singular worst
strikes they have done thus far and an
air strike an Israeli air strike hit the
alahi hospital in Gaza City where
thousands of civilians were seeking
medical treatment and Shelter From the
Relentless bombing campaign now
interestingly when that when you were
saying that uh I was coming on air too
and I took a position uh based probably
on 30 years of being a journalistically
running major new newspapers working at
CNN and others uh of waiting of just
saying I think we should just wait and
see what has actually happened here get
clarification see who's actually to
blame before we start passing judgment
you raced in to assume as many people
did by the way including the New York
Times BBC mainstream media uh and of
course most of the Arab world uh Then
followed that this was clearly uh
indisputably an Israeli air strike or
Mish hospital and yet all the evidence
now suggests very strongly that it
wasn't that in fact this was a rocket
that misi coming from a terrorist inside
Gaza so my question for you is this why
would why would you why would you be so
certain in in what you said before you
knew okay so first and foremost before
we get started on this conversation
let's understand something very
important here there's no electricity in
Gaza internet is patchy in Gaza there's
no food in Gaza there's no water in Gaza
this is all by Design This is because
Gaza is under a brutal blockade a brutal
occupation by the Israeli government
okay so that that plays a role in the
fog of war and misinformation then get
spread having said that however uh you
uh you made it seem as though there is a
certainty that this was uh 100% not an
Israeli airri in I literally just said I
literally just said it's not certainty
okay sorry I said the the evidence is
increasingly pointing to this not being
an Israeli air strike and that is expert
evidence from people who have no skin in
the game at
all Yes uh well I don't know which
expert you're you're talking about
because I think Channel 4 did a pretty
good job as a matter of fact I would say
Channel 4 did probably the best job so
far in analyzing everything that the IDF
has said but the reason why I believed
and I still do believe that the
likelihood is that this was an Israeli
bombing campaign wasn't only because of
the singular verifiable video the the
phone video from the balcony that uh had
all of the markings of an air strike the
fact that the Israeli Air Force was
enacting a bombing campaign in the
region at the time according to the aler
live streaming footage that everyone is
using but doesn't understand uh the fact
that uh the the uh dig media person uh
for the IDF uh immediately came out and
and said that this was actually an air
strike that hit a Hamas Target and that
he was sad that there were you know uh
casualties at the end of the day but
this this was a Hamas Target and
celebrated it and more importantly I
guess the fact that this hospital had
been bombed by Israel this hospital had
been bombed by Israel on Saturday 22
hospitals have as a matter of fact been
bombed by Israel since this last uh Saga
in the occupation and this hospital had
been bombed directly by Israel where the
Cancer Ward was destroyed Israel has
been bombing all of these hospitals
Israel has been calling all of these
hospitals to evacuate over and over and
over again the medical professionals at
the hospital had been called by the
Israeli government uh the day prior and
everyone on the ground assumes that this
is an Israeli air strike they are the
ones who experien situation so when you
have when you have single can I BBC if
you watch the BBC account of all this
last night by their verify unit which
was specifically set up by the BBC to be
completely dispassionate in these
investigations and they reached a pretty
clear conclusion based on circumstantial
evidence I'll make that clear that this
would not have been an Israeli air
strike including for example the size of
the crater which Bears no relation to
the size of crater's normally left by
Israel so look my point is neither of us
know for sure but you took to your
Airwaves in immediately because actually
your I wouldn't even say unconscious
bias your admitted propagandist bias on
your part was that you wanted that to be
an Israeli air strike it suited your
narrative and I would say that that in
itself in its way stenographer well you
know you accuse me of being a
sonographer I try and be fair and get to
the truth in your case I don't think you
try to do that I think you appeal to
your audience appeal to your base and
you don't really care whether the facts
are there or not
this is entirely unfair because you just
said circumstantial evidence favors that
this was not an Israeli airstrike I gave
you all of the circumstantial evidence
that does favor that this is an Israeli
air strike the reason why however
circumstantial evidence is not enough
and the one thing that I will concede to
because when more information did come
out and no I do not mean when Israel
said that they did not bomb this
hospital and it was actually Hamas and
then they turned around and went never
mind it's not Hamas it's actually
Islamic Jihad and then they said we have
more evidence coming out in a couple
hours and then the evidence came out and
it turns out it sounded like uh it the
the phone conversations that they were
able to intercept supposedly uh sounded
like uh by experts at the very least uh
to be uh completely false and and uh
completely made
up I don't think even you're saying let
me finish I think you're a smart guy let
me finish I think you've looked at all
of this and I think in your heart you
know this was probably not an Israeli
air strike and I'm just curious why you
would instead of admitting that as facts
change your opinion say that is not what
I'm saying at all I don't understand why
you would double and treble
down you're asking me to be on your show
do you want to talk yes if you're asking
me to be on your show and I want to be
on the show thank you so much for having
me on your show let me explain exactly
what I said and let me explain to you
why I think still to this very moment
until there is a thirdparty
investigation that is conclud included
by uh the UN the international criminal
court or specifically a forensic analyst
that uh that looks at the situation is
allowed to be on the ground this is not
just my perspective this is BET selum as
well which is an Israeli organization
that has also demanded a third party
investigation occur I am not going to I
am not going to conclusively say that
this was not I fault because I just gave
you because I and not because I'm a
propagandist as far as me being a
propagandist goes everyone is a
propagandist I'm just honest about it
you're a propagandist we have our bi who
you think propagandist honest about my
biases who do you think I'm a
propagandist for who do I think you're a
propagandist for whichever your every
every media person is is doing
propaganda this but who but who for I've
got to be doing it with somebody you
think it's a bad word I don't that's
just the difference this a semantic
actually quite a serious charge H I
think it's a serious charge to level not
as a podcaster but as a journalist
broadcasting around the world who has a
reputation I believe for being fair and
impartial actually on these issues is
quite a charge to just say I'm a
stenographer of the Israeli government
or I'm a propagandist I don't think
there's any evidence I'm either of those
things I'm curious who you think I'm
doing while we're having this
conversation 3,000 peers while we're
having this back and forth
3,8 40 Palestinians have been ruthlessly
slaughtered in the last incursion into
Gaza I feel like this is an
incredibly selfish self-centered
conversation to have you asked me to be
on here you wanted you wanted to hear my
perspective I'm willing to give it to
you I don't want to talk about like
whether the I don't want to talk about
Nome Chomsky style manufacturing consent
conversations about how the media is
operating in the in the the beest of the
there are dead people listen son I only
asked you because you're the guy that
called me a propagandist and called me a
baboon in the suit I was curious as to
why you don't want to say
propanda we'll move on we'll move on I
agree with you there's a bigger there's
a bigger picture here let's move on
let's take a short break let's take a
short break I want to come back I want
to talk to you about what happened on
October the 7th get your reaction to
that welcome back Hassan perer is still
with me asan I want to just play you a
clip of something that you said about
the uh October 7th Terror attacks and in
particular the attack at the music
festival which killed 260 people look at
this guy you know what shouldn't happen
killing 260 people at a Music Festival
no you're right man that just happened
on its own cuz like bad guys wanted to
do bad things you're right dude if they
subjugated you to a open air prison your
whole life you're going to break out
eventually when you realize that there's
no other way to get out of it I mean it
sounds to me there
Hassan that you are in some way saying
they had it coming will
you um no I wouldn't say that they had
it coming I think that uh Michael Brooks
used to say uh analysis is not
justification and while obviously
civilian casualties and and horrific
barbaric acts that were committed on
October 7 are completely
unacceptable uh the the important thing
to make sure that it never happens again
is to analyze what are the conditions as
to as to how it happened to begin with
and I think uhud Barack is going to be
on uh in a little bit as well or maybe
he's on before me uh and and I'm and I'm
almost certain that while he has held
the keys to the conversation and held
the the levers of the power in this
conversation in many key and critical
points uh I I would go so far say that
he is among many others who also
recognize that the BB Netanyahu
Administration is responsible this is
not just my assessment this is uh 85% of
the uh Israeli populations assessment at
the time uh this is years and years and
years of refusing to negotiate with the
Palestinian Authority take don't take my
word for it take personal word for it a
closed door conversation with lud
members he said that if you want to
thwart any kind of Palestinian nation
state you must do everything you can to
only negotiate with Hamas we control how
high the how high the fire goes he has
given cash to Hamas by way of Qatar uh
there is no bigger fan of Hamas than
Biby Netanyahu which uh I hope one day
you can maybe uh interview and then
you'll ask him to no I I actually did
interview him a few months ago and I I
did actually spell out to him that there
would been a lot more Palestinian deaths
this year so far up to the point of the
interview than Israelis and what he
intended to do about it he said then he
didn't believe in Collective
responsibility which is now this hot
phrase in this whole uh crisis about
whether you would hold all people in
Gaza responsible for Hamas interesting
to see if when they let me just finish
my point if they do then launch a ground
Invasion it be interesting to see if
they keep to that word you know I'm not
a I'm not I'm not a a defender of what B
Netanyahu has been doing in Israel in
the last year his attack on The
credibility and integrity of the Supreme
Court I think it's been a disgrace and I
think it has fractured Society in Israel
I also think that it's caused so much
social unrest and had such big protests
that you could argue it's taken the eye
off the ball of the people who should
have been defending the Border uh
because they've been trying to sort out
what's been going on domestically
internally inside Israel so I think it's
a catastrophic failure of intelligence
of security of Defense all of those
things I'd be amazed frankly if
Netanyahu survives this so I'm certainly
not here to defend him even if you do
view me as a stenographer for his
government uh my my question for you I
think is this is I've had a lot of
problems trying to get people on the pro
Palestinian side to separate two things
that you can say as I believe and you
believe that the Palestinians have been
maltreated for decades that the
situation where they are effectively I
mean I don't even call it an occupation
because Israelis aren't in Gaza they
pulled out in 2005 but they still
control the ability of G this is why I
call you propaganda no no I'm just
saying the phraseology is confusing to
me because the reality is Israel
exercises control over people in Gaza it
allows them in and out it allows them to
turn on the tap of water and so on and
so on I get all that they don't actually
live there because they can't live side
by side with why it's called an open air
prison right I don't disagre call the
world's largest open a pron Hass I don't
disagree with you and I've I've pointed
this out for a long time as a journalist
so we don't we don't disagree about the
appalling plight of Palestinian people
um but the issue comes that if you can't
separate that ongoing dispute between
Israel and Palestine from the absolutely
appalling barbarism of October the 7th
which was on a whole different scale to
anything we've seen where 1,400
people Holocaust Survivors babies in
their in their cribs you know young
women taken uh tortured abused shot
beheaded with it was reported and so on
if we can't look at that collectively
with a with a a general humanity and
agreement that that is an absolute
atrocity then there's something wrong
with this and I find that the tribalism
on both sides is now so toxic and so
frenzied that you get people who
literally can't we've had a bunch of
actors right signing this statement
saying they want a ceasefire in Gaza and
calling Israel war criminals and so on
but they don't say a word about the
Hamas attacks that precipitated this and
I find that really hard to accept but
but you but do you agree with them if if
they had said for example that October 7
attacks were brutal and and massacres
occurred and then they said everything
else that Israel is committing war
crimes would you agree with them well
okay here's what I would honestly say
about that is Israel not allowed to
defend itself from the worst terror
attack we've seen since 911 is it not
allowed to defend itself after, 1400
people in Israel are butchered that way
and the question then if you assume that
they are able to defend themselves as
any free Democratic country the is State
Department line that is the 's line that
is the line that everyone let me ask you
this it then becomes a question of how
can they defend themselves if their
mission now is to get rid of Hamas a
terror organization that's committed one
of the worst acts of Terror ever seen if
that is their stated aim then what they
are doing is consistent with that isn't
it no here's why this is actually an
abject failure and this is not just my
perspective on the matter I'm just a you
know dumb idiot with a twitch stream who
who is live reacting to the news and
trying to make sense of everything as
it's ongoing I usually have a policy of
not covering breaking news and and uh
sometimes that policy is violated but
ultimately I am not held up by the same
journalistic standards even though I
think I do a much better job than most
other news outlets in uh in general so
let me just say this really quickly you
said Israel has a right to defend itself
absolutely zero people think that this
is a ridiculous statement however how
Israel is defending itself is collective
punishment now Collective punishment in
the form of depriving 2.2 million people
of electricity Collective punishment in
the form of depriving them of of water
of food Collective punishment of uh in
the form of 51 people dying in the West
Bank where you know there is no Hamas in
the West Bank and yet 51 people have
died because in the West Bank settlers
that are occupying Palestinian territory
in violation of the international law
settlers who are doing an act of
colonial terrorism and this is not my
statement on it this is international
law that are doing horrifying things by
simply just existing isting there and
and maintaining the presence with a with
an occupying force in the form of IDF
who was ritualistically humiliating
Palestinians uh uh in in a in a
structure that bet selum an Israeli
organization calls the permit regime
where every waking moment of of uh
Palestinians lives in the West Bank are
absolute hell where they have no legal
recourse 51 Palestinians have died and
that was before the ramola uh the the
rala protest that happened last night
and uh the Israeli forces were uh
opening up with live fire on protesters
last night so who knows what that death
toll has become this is all this is all
a product of Israel being an apartheid
state this is a violent apartheid state
there is no way to be a
peaceful it is a violence violence
required for its maintenance and that
violence is frustrating people that
violence is radicalizing people on as
far as is as far
as as far as what Benjamin Netanyahu has
done as far as the war government what
they have done peers going into Gaza
yeah and bombing Gaza and killing
3,480 uh Palestinians so far in Gaza
1,000 plus children out of all of those
casualties 22 hospitals being bombed a
bakery the only remaining intact Bakery
being bombed yesterday um these are
these are horrifying crimes
that you would open say are horrifying
and unjustifiable when Russia does it
but when Israel does it Israel has a
right to defend itself this is identical
to the same talking points that I've
heard from every Israeli Administration
official it's the same talking points
that I've heard from American
politicians championing the the exact
same talking point it's the same thing
that I've heard from everyone else in
the media you might have been against
the Iraq uh war and and you use that but
you're using that for for evil in my
opinion at this point if you are not
sitting here and condemning those acts
of war crimes those acts of violence
that those acts of collective punishment
well I would say to that that I think
the death of any child in this conflict
is horrific absolutely horrific but the
question comes down to me that after an
act of Terror as we saw on October the
7th Israel should be able to defend
itself and should be able to go after
the people that perpetrated that who
live among civilians in in Gaza
deliberately and the question for me
becomes down to what is proportionate I
don't know the answer that I'll be
honest with you I don't know what that
answer is I do know the answer to that I
do know the answer to that last night I
had uh Dr ofer kasif uh an Israeli
knesset member who was expelled uh
suspended for 45 days for saying uh what
I believe is the truth uh What uh
championing the exact same position of
the uh the harat's editorial board um
there are a lot of thoughtful people a
lot of um uh formative Holocaust
Scholars a lot of historians uh that all
agree on the same point the reason why
violence that even penetrates through
the Israeli security blanket that that
people thought existed that penetrated
through that Iron Dome the Iron Wall if
you want to call it that is because of
years and years of Oppression and years
and years of violence which is a
necessity to maintain an apartheid state
and this has to stop there's only two
ways out of this either you engage in
full-blown ethnic cleansing and if you
if you listen to the likes of smotrich
or if you listen to the likes of itamar
bangir and these very unfavorable
unpopular far-right figures if you
listen to Netanyahu and his lud
government uh they say that they are
interested in going in that direction
the ethnic cleansing Direction the
ethnic displacement direction or the
only way out of this for a real solution
is to to move towards peace to genuinely
have to genuinely end the blockade to
end the aparte to end the occupation and
create a pathway towards citizenship for
all people with a right to return for uh
all 14 million Palestinians uh uh 5
million of which live under Israeli
occupation it's brutal and then the rest
living in diaspora these are not
unreasonable requests these are requests
that understand the dignity and the
humanity of one side and does simply
treat them as their their colonial
subjects and and it's the only way to
create permanent security and prosperity
in the region if it was as simple as
that I'm sure that would have happened
already I would say this I agree with a
lot of what you've just said not all of
it a lot of it I don't think you can
ever achieve peace now with Hamas
controlling Gaza I don't think you can
achieve peace with Netanyahu in charge
of Israel actually after I don't think
his own people will want him to be in
charge of Israel down the line when they
examine exactly how this happened but we
will see uh but Hass I got to leave it
there look it's good to talk to you you
know you're an important influential
voice to a lot of people um and I I
think we have a lot of common ground and
there are some things that we disagree
about but I suspect it's not as much as
you think you know I do think that the
core problem here has got to get
resolved in a way that's been completely
ignored for decades and until it gets
resolved until the plot of the
Palestinian people is resolved until all
these young people in Palestine feel
there's some sense of hope and they get
out of what effectively is as you say a
prison camp then nothing is going to
change uh I don't think it
justifies say I've got to finish it but
I don't think it justifies in any way
what happened on October the 7th but I
do agree with you that until that core
problem gets resolved there will never
be peace H I appreciate you joining me
thank you very
much thank you for having
me